well how's it going on your other job
you have all the jobs
um the neighborhood yeah you have a lot
of jobs I have a lot of jobs but you
have a lot too so how's the neighbor
going uh the neighborhood's great yeah
it has been amazing we're in our fourth
season
is the greatest she loves you okay shoes
will come in and she's like this oh my
God
I think it's so nice she actually does
do it
I love no but when she was on here
um it reminds me she was saying that she
gave away like some kind of butter to
feed butterflies she gave something away
to like all her neighbors did she give
it to you too it was like she flowers
like milkweed or something she's there's
some sort of plant or animal because
milkweed she gave it to her she didn't
give you any oh she didn't make the cut
apparently not she didn't want
butterflies at your house
no I think she did it for her neighbors
I just thought what a beautiful thing
and like such a random thing to do for
your neighbors but you don't even really
know what she did you she looked at her
neighbors and she gave the Milky to like
plant so they could have butterflies I
don't even know what milk we did do you
know it's a plant right like a flower
see you don't even know what it is well
I know what a weed is milkweed like it's
a flower I feel like it's a flower and
and so feel like it attracts butterflies
I think that's beautiful she's the
butterfly neighborhood look there's uh
at the intentions of Beth bears are all
beautiful
did she send you these flowers probably
he did actually give me a plan
[Music]